okay is this texting working again
nobody knows adios muchacho
okay residue prog Oh in this here thank
y'all
okay I think we're back hold on let me
just check to make sure that thinks del
recording Jesus okay I look talking
about recording God you gotta love
electronics okay okay anyway it's your
boy psychobabble and we're back with
Black Mesa oh what's the Hat
okay let game where's it at processing
residue processing okay I played this
game again you like yesterday because I
didn't know what else to play very two
days ago and and it was actually fun so
I was like maybe we get back to it wait
why don't I remember this
stupid headcrabs oh wait I had like no
ammo yeah the fit you stupid [ __ ] eBay
but you feel pretty embarrassed right
now after this class wow I'm getting
really messed up here anyway
miss radiation is very screwy I wonder
is it like affecting me I can't tell
no it's not okay anyways alright climb
up that stand out what I'm saying
yeah now what I'm saying okay I guess I
got it on there now what what is going
on here I feel like I should be going in
there
I really suck I maybe got to turn off
that gas first out okay I just broke
something let me just make sure nothing
else is here Oakley for going out of
town okay not it out of my way
yes yep catch okay I'll say here
Oh Jay says oh man I was gonna get
sucked up okay well this I got a gap you
know the most important tool you can
have and any workman's shed is the gap
okay so how do you reload our check
oh I got crap on me wow this place is
gigantic take like ten years for me to
figure everything here
what is the what is the point of this
up crap they change weapons locked okay
okay chargers amp date just great you
know just what I wanted I can't look I
got all his crap on my stuff okay let's
get the heck back here we got way too
much stuff going on right now you know
it's weird there's like no secrets in
this game that's what I find kind of
weird like there's no like you don't
really get a lot of hidden hidden stuff
going on
oh crap
like it it a edit how dare you got this
okay I just wasted so much ammo turn out
this flame there where you go now I
could probably go back in that hole you
know right there awesome
say I'm sorry I'm pretty proud at this I
know a lot of you will say like yeah
psychology you pro in anything and I say
like a lot of things you know and this
just goes to show like what I am Pro out
of my way
I'm almost like too pro for life you
know can I get up there and I can't
let's going on here I can I get out of
here the hell is this okay when I said
there's going to be an ambush or
something
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
not exactly sure what I'm doing here
stick it on there or is that a horrible
idea
[Applause]
something tells me not to go down there
Oh raining down a No
hey then crap down there
[Music]
okay here we go see that fast I got
ballot that's it I hear something
[Music]
holy crap
okay
okay
was this a waste of time I ain't waste
of time in out
how do you
now how do you sprint again
let me try that sprint one last time
night turns off yeah
[ __ ] okay yeah so no idea I let me go
back let me go back by something going
on weird here we're going to turn off
the gas or something I don't get in
there what the hell I see the lotto it's
check real quick right Jonathan Elton
here oh this is the Hat
weird
maybe I can like
carried boxes or something to get up
there you know
and
okay come on come on
anything up here I gotta do now
okay I'm back in here
mmm there's definitely something going
on here
oh I made it
to help
what the hell is that over there
can't escape luck in yes camp lock-in
and I'm supposed to go from here on to
there that is a horrible idea but it
really looks that way
okay okay no she's dead
give me that
so so these unlock all these like weird
doors you just open it in case someone
happens are you know where it goes
there we go this is way ahead
ooh okay looks like I'm a little pro at
this enough ma it's like I'm not in the
sciencing anymore I'm just like in
garbage land yep tell me where those
guys like I'm on my GoPro right there
yeah made that god damn a is that God I
know you got kids in here
well that goes
now wait
okay do not want to fall down there
that's for sure okay
did I should I try the story or my
cologne crazy okay
I love this kind of stuff when you're
just like trying to get down safely
don't know why it's just fun to me
the flow that is so dope no no I like
stuff like that
well it's certainly not going to back up
so they said first one here
here's not okay I am screwed
it seems I'm screwed do I gotta go down
there
alright here are nothing holy cannoli
how do I get down there I'm going to
drown how do I go down
okay here it goes how do I do it Oh what
is that now
I did a lot I play nice Beckett okay in
this pocket are
what the hell is going on
where am I the preliminary clarifiers
waste-treatment I'm probably near
freaking cancer from all this stuff
hello
I guess I can go under there
you just check this real quick okay
looks like I'm going through more
toeside back less they go up can't go
off at all think I maybe I can pipes
looks like
there's a door right there
holy smokes
okay maybe I'm in the right place then I
have no idea where I am
okay cannot swim backwards I can only go
forward can't go on there
what is that out
and law oh my god I need air I did air I
can't say anything Oh ma'am okay what
the heck
Jeana that was crazy I don't know what
the heck I just went through what is
this a bomb a weird
I hate this place songs to shut it down
charge of course the charges that thing
why wonder that right can they shoot me
so you sound bright flower plays on
break
let me let me eliminate this foul is
that why you I want to grow the do you
just want to get popped like your
brother
and they sink down here yes I just want
to get pops like his brother you know
some people I just want to do that it's
like a family thing I have no idea where
I'm going
baby yeah yeah yeah okay I turn this off
okay
that is open now
well hold their Tiger you got about you
better we tell me where I'm going first
if I jump down there
okay I guess I'm just going in there now
I'm just a piece of trash now I guess
you know just a piece of trash
okay you know what happened to trash
moving parts and operate keep off right
okay I'm a pancake now
oh god I get spread
how's that right like I can't even
follow the track just be sad
okay
okay there's some crazy music playing
here
okay I don't want to go there so
you better shut down this whole
operation
perfect there's contest of course okay
of course
oh now mind if I do
ow
got to go in there I think right
[Music]
look at this stupid vial of getting
grinded up
comp or a okay
holy cannoli that almost fell to my -
okay I did my god I get out of here
where the heck am i what
where
and I get back up
I have no idea how to get back
I just kind of keep going up then I
guess - it's over here Oh quick
whoa Shh
okay we're back in business we're back
in business okay
okay it's kind of obvious where we got
to go
see how this is up here it seems that we
have to go see somebody got burned up
here
yes yes right now okay see this I got to
somehow move this
kind of luck here
and out that door goes anywhere
I go down there can I get back up
okay I can't
let's go anywhere
that doesn't go anywhere
you
hey check out what's in there request
Oh
it's just like Oh
well there was a blue laser here but it
blew it up okay and we say Moses go
oh ho there's Sally Oh
well I have so far to go again this is
insane this is insane okay I want to
beat this level and then I'm just gonna
go back to I'm gonna call today so I'm I
don't know where the other steroid goes
I do not care I do not care
like I'm a and just a piece of trash
again I'm going to burn up again and we
get burned up again I'll shoot
I hate this thing
okay
and that son we are one and the son we
are to gather up wait they went this way
yeah now I was like right around here
that I could spell off okay okay oh my
god there we go she goes
Oh
okay I feel like we're going the right
way now
weird
I would take the branch or something
okay
Wow okay I think we're going places now
and I feel like we're making the
difference in the world
okay loading okay I'm gonna end this
here thank y'all for watching what god I
hope it doesn't crash huh okay save is
here okay I have to watch anything else
I'd go ok haters it's your boy
psychobabble and he's back with another
adventure of like myself it's just
working these things it is working I
guess and I'm honest right here
I think when with that top of a ladder
and I had no idea where I'm going but
you know that's that's this game you
know that's really this game you really
just give you a crowbar they say here is
like a vast go for it like who knows
where you'll end up you know like I
don't folks they're alive
Wow painful and oh they're like any
cages wait come on a reset because I
should have really just taken out of the
pistol add another bat damaging their
way down that's how you do it around
here that's how you it out okay at the
bottom you notice this notice has been
noted and then he continued
participation noticing you notice we
noted a report bendable darn good get
get them out that's what I like in this
camp okay
[Music]
nope nothing there okay it seems like I
have to go up here
maybe we have to go all of types now
[Applause]
again higher I supposed to jump over
this thing right go to I they're down
there not only room to go on a ceiling
mmm
its egg once again macular in a
predicament you know like we're an
afflicted
how the heck do I look hot your topic
okay I'm looking at it there's a poll
there sure can't enter you what is this
is that Wallace you get it says arrow no
this way and just that's definitely
there's only one way to go there
um maybe I have to scale it you know
can I move these things these are so
gross and fire protection water
Gary something like this right that's
good no no
oh my cat does scary
[Applause]
air supply
[Applause]
can't go in there okay give it boys
stripping
yeah I say I say now okay
I thought you guys are too smart for
psycho Valley
you're not you guys are tears come on
let me tell you something you want okay
what is that called a